l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
dernier rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça faut ça fout les jetons
on est dans une espèce de déni collectif
on ne veut pas croire ce qu'on sait et
scientifique parle quand même de la
sixième extinction de la vie sur terre
sixième extinction et la vie sur terre
il ya d'autres experts qui contestent
leur usine en chine
personne non non c'est pas vrai il ya
des crimes à tous et maintenant et non
ce n'est pas il y en a pas il ya des
gens qui ne sont pas des chercheurs qui
parlent que la presse met en avant parce
que il faut que du débat il ya plus de
débat aujourd'hui il n'y a plus aucun
débat ce changement climatique et on va
vers une vraie par une catastrophe ou 20
vers une vraie catastrophe et on est
incapable d'en prendre conscience
mais ce n'est pas des pessimistes de
comprendre ce qui va arriver pour moi je
pense qu'on est comme une guerre
aujourd'hui on est entré en guerre
contre nos façons vu et l'ennemi y'en a
pas d'ennemis l'ennemi c'est nous
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour pékin
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
des commémorations de la victoire sur
l'allemagne nazie moins grandiose que
d'habitude en russie pas de défilé
militaire sur la place rouge mais une
parade aérienne maintenu après un dépôt
de roses devant la flamme du soldat
inconnu le chef du kremlin a célébré
dans son discours je cite la russie inde
ainsi
lorsqu'elle est unie les deux lignes
rouges levait pour une adoption
définitive de la prolongation de la loi
sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire en france
après un bras de fer cette semaine
sénateurs et députés ont trouvé un
compromis sur la responsabilité pénale
des décideurs ainsi que sur la mise en
place du suivi des malades
point sensible qui ont fait l'objet d'un
bras de fer cette semaine
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce samedi les
célébrations du 75e anniversaire de la
victoire des russes sur l'allemagne
nazie
après l'armistice signé par les alliés
le 8 mai 1945 la reddition définitive et
paraphé au quartier général de l'union
soviétique à berlin juste après minuit
d'où cette date du 9 mai retenu par la
russie le pays qui rend hommage donc
aujourd'hui aux 27 millions de
soviétiques morte pour leur patrie une
grande fête nationale moins grandiose
que d'habitude à cause de la crise
sanitaire on va le voir et c'est donc
sans public dans les rues de moscou sans
défilé militaire sur la place rouge que
la russie à célébrer le 75e anniversaire
du 9 mai 1945
seul le volet aérien du défilé militaire
traditionnel vous le voyez a été
maintenue des dizaines d'avions de
chasse des avions de reconnaissance de
ravitaillement ainsi que des
hélicoptères ont survolé moscou au
dessus de la classe rouge une escadrille
a même dessiné avec ces fumigènes le
drapeau russe blanc bleu rouge dans le
ciel de la capitale et le chef du
kremlin lui a prononcé un saut une sobre
allocution après avoir rendu hommage aux
quelque 27 millions de morts soviétiques
voyez les précisions de notre
correspondant antoine claireaux depuis
la place rouge à moscou
c'est une impression très étrange très
bizarre de se trouver sur la place rouge
1 9 mai sur une place rouge complètement
vide complètement déserte alors qu'en
temps normal 1 9 mai cet endroit est
plein à craquer le long des murs du
kremlin se trouve normalement une
immense tribune qui accueille
l'état-major de l'armée russe des
anciens combattants ou encore les chefs
d'état et autres dignitaires étrangers
cette année devait participer le
président chinois xi jinping ou encore
le président français emmanuel macron
mais voilà coronavirus oblige
rien de tout ça vladimir poutine était
néanmoins présent il a déposé une gerbe
de fleurs sur la tombe du soldat inconnu
avant ensuite de délivrer un message à
la nation je vous propose d'écouter une
partie de son intervention
je suis certain que dans des décennies
et des siècles le mode sera toujours
reconnaissant au peuple soviétique
cette génération des vainqueurs restera
à jamais
l'exemple du dénouement sacré à notre
patrie à notre terre l'armée et la
marine de la fédération de russie qui
ont prouvé lors des opérations contre le
terrorisme international tout en
accomplissant des missions pour la
sécurité du pays
la cérémonie officielle s'est poursuivie
avec le passage en revue par vladimir
poutine de la garde d'honneur du
régiment présidentiel ensuite pas de
parade militaire au sens où on l'entend
traditionnellement mais néanmoins la
parade aérienne qui elle a été maintenue
c'est donc 75 appareils qui ont survolé
la place rouge 20 hélicoptères ainsi que
55 avions militaires s'en suit en temps
normal la marche du régiment immortel
toute cette foule d'anonymes qui défile
avec à la main le portrait d'un proche
un père un grand père en arrière grand
père qui a participé de près ou de loin
à l'effort de guerre de cette seconde
guerre mondiale à la place cette année
c'est en ligne que cela puisse passer la
population a été invitée à déposer ces
témoignages sur un site internet dédié
c'est donc un 9 mai exceptionnel à plus
d'un titre qui va se clore dans la
soirée avec un grand feu d'artifice
coronavirus ou pas en france
l'ambassadeur de russie a rendu hommage
à ses compatriotes qui ont combattu dans
les rangs de la résistance française il
a déposé une couronne de fleurs au pied
du monument aux morts c'est une statue
qui est situé au cimetière du père
lachaise
arrondissement de paris alexei markov a
salué une victoire commune de la russie
et de la france écoutez le je pense que
c'est notre victoire commune aux pieds
pas deviennent donc les françaises
célèbres tout d'abord leur victoire
aussi participer avec nous à cette
guerre affreuse la diaspora russe des
toits tous les efforts possibles pour
que les célébrations du jour de la
victoire soit à la hauteur
c'est à dire ce qui est les prisonniers
de guerre soviétiques les résistances
soviétiques ont apporté une contribution
importante à la victoire sur le fascisme
en france tout chose faisait partie de
ce vaste groupe réunissant quarante
mille personnes et vous présentons ce 17
nations dix sept pays
combattez ici modo la morgue avec leurs
frères français contre le fascisme et
leurs noms sont inscrits en lettres d'or
dans l'histoire française
un épisode peu connu de cette seconde
guerre mondiale à présent celui des
rodina qui veut dire patrie en russe
c'est le nom choisi par l'unique
bataillon de la résistance composé par
des femmes 37 femmes qui ont réussi à
s'évader de leurs camps de concentration
en meurthe et moselle et qui ont décidé
de poursuivre le combat contre le
nazisme
regardez nous emmener nous étions 12 à
la gestapo il y a eu un interrogatoire
j'avais détresse épaisse alors ils m'ont
tiré par les tresses et ils m'ont mis un
coup de poing dans le visage
vous savez c'est une histoire qui me
hantaient salaires
e
[Musique]
et lorsqu'elles sont arrivées en france
qu'elle se sont évadés elle avait gardé
intacte cette motivation
cette obstination à combattre le
fascisme et elles ont trouvé le même
enthousiasme de combat avec nos
partisans français et elle se sent il se
sont compris rapidement malgré la
barrière de la langue et ils ont
organisé cette évasion
c'était une longue un long processus une
langue organisation qui a pu se réaliser
avec succès il y avait des ouvriers
français des hommes qui avaient noué des
liens avec nos filles et ils l'auront
confié on vous aidera à vous évader du
camp de concentration d'hérouville vers
la forêt
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
autre histoire digne d'être connue celle
d'une autrichienne dont la mère a sauvé
deux soldats soviétiques pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale ces deux
militaires avaient eux aussi réussi à
s'évader de leur camp de concentration
regarder des sirènes hurlaient il
parcourait les villages avec des
haut-parleurs et disait que de dangereux
criminels s'étaient échappés et qu'il
fallait les à battre à mains nues en les
poignardant ou en leur tirant dessus
evans m
[Musique]
on
oh
[Musique]
bien s'endort en ira t elle nous vivions
à 10 11 km du camp de concentration
ils ont eu le courage de venir chez nous
rien que ça c'était effrayant
l'un des soldats nikai à frapper à notre
porte
ma mère est allée à la porte dehors il y
avait un homme
il a dit je suis un interprète de
l'hymne s'il vous plaît donnez moi
quelque chose à manger et ma mère a pris
sa main un 10 ans je sais qui tu es et
péter motta
[Musique]
destin elle a emmené mikail dans la
cuisine et lui attirant moi aussi j'ai
cinq fils qui sont partis pour la guerre
et je veux que tout le monde rentre chez
soi après tout toi aussi tu as une merde
à temps
cours
[Musique]
des moteurs maman disait je n'ai pas six
mais huit fils nous étions une seule
famille lui nous aimions c'était des
frères pour moi comme les autres
un gouffre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maman raconte et cela de manière très
émouvante
cette toute petite femme m'a presque
étouffée dans ses bras elle est montée à
l'étagé avec ma mère est là il y avait
une icône de la vierge
[Musique]
ces deux femmes ne pouvaient pas se
parler
l'une ne connaissait pas l'allemand
l'autre le russes mais il ya les gestes
elle pointait sans cesse l'icône est
serré ma mère dans ces braves dames
[Musique]
des célébrations également dans les
autres villes de russie une parade
aérienne à sébastopol au dessus de la
péninsule de crimée fanfare militaire à
saint pétersbourg des chants
patriotiques également à kaliningrad ou
encore un défilé militaire mais sans
public évidemment à volgograd voilà pour
ces festivités réduites au strict
minimum à cause des restrictions
sanitaires des festivités décalé de 24
heures donc entre la france et la russie
voyez les explications de gérard
vespière il est chercheur associé à la
fondation d'études pour le moyen-orient
entre le décalage entre la signature
effectivement en france et puis la
signature ensuite à à berlin donc il ya
ces 24 heures de différence qui explique
la donc le passage de l'horaire de
minuit à entre le 8 et le 9 d'à côté
donc elle de l'horaire français et de
l'autre côté de l'horaire moscou aux
moscovites
eh bien il est tout à fait normal comme
il y a eu donc des retrouvailles
mondiale sur les plages de normandie
qu'il y ait aussi des retrouvailles
mondiale sur la place rouge où au lieu
choisi par le pouvoir à moscou pour
célébrer cet événement des 75 ans est
tout à fait logique lier ce parallèle
cette symétrie entre les plages de
normandie et puis la place rouge rt sur
le web les informations à retrouver sur
notre site
rt france point tv le fait chaud et
humide
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministère
des armées en rendant hommage aux alliés
de la france hier geneviève darrieussecq
a oublié un pays la russie les
explications avoir sur notre site
internet
l'histoire touchante de ces deux opus
qui se retrouvent soixante dix huit ans
plus tard elles avaient été séparés lors
des terribles bombardements de
stalingrad en 1942 après plusieurs
années de recherches les deux femmes le
voyait sont de nouveau réunis
et puis l'épisode méconnu des
combattants russes engagés dans la
résistance française 4000 à 5000 émigrés
russes qui ont combattu aux côtés
d'autres nationalités
pendant la seconde guerre mondiale un
détachement soviétique qui avait pu
défiler sur les champs-elysées lors de
la libération de paris c'était le 26
août 1944
[Musique]
et on en vient à la faune démis du
coronavirus avec ce bilan en france à
moins de deux jours due déconfinement
243 décès supplémentaires ces dernières
24 heures pour un total de 26 mille deux
cent trente morts les patients en
réanimation sont toujours de moins en
moins nombreux chaque jour avec 2008 168
personnes toujours hospitalisées
et puis sachez qu'en dordogne plusieurs
nouveaux 4 coronavirus ont été détectés
suite à un rassemblement familial après
des funérailles le préfet dénonce
relâchement mais pour l'instant ce neuf
personnes ont été testées positives
la loi sur le prolongement de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée nationale ce soir pour
validation définitive après un bras de
fer cette semaine elle sénateurs et
députés ont pu trouver un compromis sur
la responsabilité pénale des décideurs
ainsi que sur la mise en place du suivi
des malades deux points sensibles qui
ont fait l'objet d'un bras de fer cette
semaine les républicains ont finalement
accepté de la voter voyez ce qu'en pense
eric coquerel député de la france
insoumise de seine saint denis
valve vient d'être adopté donc il ya un
accord entre le sénat et l'assemblée et
tout à l'heure c'est à 18h donc que
l'assemblée va voter définitivement le
texte qui a fait compromis avec le sénat
mais nous voterons toujours content
parce que nous allons les modifications
qui ont été apportées ne seront pas du
tout de nature à nous rassurer
toutes les mesures que nous proposions
d'un point de vue social ont été soit
refusée soit jugée recevable par exemple
la gratuité des masques par exemple ne
pas mettre des amendes à des gens qui à
partir de lundi on est obligé de prendre
les transports et qui en plus ils n'ont
pas de base peuvent se voir infliger des
amendes on pense qu'on ferait mieux de
leur donner un masque par exemple
interdire les licenciements tout un tas
de mesures pour essayer de faire face à
la crise sociale qui maintenant s'empare
du pays voilà pour toutes ces raisons
nous avons voté contre
on en vient à cette lettre ouverte des
journalistes de défense français il y
dénonce aussi des dysfonctionnements
multiples est récurrent dans la
communication du ministère des armées
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire d
elles entravent encore plus qu'avant
selon eux l'exercice de leur métier de
spécialiste défense absence de réponses
étayées en temps et en heure aux
questions posées sélection arbitraire
des journalistes ayant accès à certaines
sources pressions exercées même sur ces
journalistes et même des mensonges
délibérés ou pas de la part de ses
communicants voilà pour la liste des
reproches et pour en parler
nous sommes en direct avec mériadec
raffray secrétaire général de la jv et
l'association des journalistes de
défense
bonsoir mériadec raffray
merci m merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors pourquoi avoir écrit cette
lettre ouverte
et quels sont précisément les griefs
vous parler de deux mensonges notamment
dans les cas de contamination au sein
des armées et goûter il y avait
effectivement une pression qui monte au
sein de des adhérents journaliste
professionnel et spécialiste des
questions de défense de l'association
des juristes de défense et à moment
donné nous sommes notre vocation est
aussi de d'être de dire les choses
porter la parole de nos de nos
journalistes camara des confrères et
effectivement ces dernières semaines il
ya eu des erreurs des maladresses des
suspicions voire même certains le disent
emploie le mot mensonge à propos comme
on dit h2o2 d'information qui donne
l'information délivrée par les
communicants de l'institution militaire
et la coupe est visiblement plein il
fallait que nous marquions le coup que
nous prenions date
il est vrai également que le climat vous
la verrez à rappeler est suspicieux là
la communication gouvernementale depuis
le début de cette crise laisse pour le
moins à désirer voire même à
véritablement chaotique et il se trouve
qu'il y avait des dysfonctionnements
structurels entre les journalistes de
défense et l'institution et la
communication de défense et que la crise
a sans doute accéléré les difficultés et
a causé un certain nombre de sujets plus
graves
il ya des problèmes autour des chiffres
du code vide dans les armées il ya des
problèmes c'est à dire mériadec raffray
à les chiffres sont inexacts ont ils été
publié difficile pour l'instant on a du
mal à démêler l'écheveau certain jo
reyes 10 effectivement que les chiffres
communiqués ont été faut d'autres disent
que le problème est la complexité des
sources
vous savez dans l'est dans l'institution
je re dans l'institution à défense vous
avez des communicants politiques vous
avez des communicants de l'institution
au niveau central qui ensuite vous avez
des communicants qui représentent les
différentes armées tout cela est un peu
complexe et peut-être il y a eu des voix
lardé des problèmes des problèmes de
complexité mais certains dénoncent
effectivement des mensonges c'est à dire
des chiffres faux délibérée ou non cela
reste aaa pas prouvé il ya eu également
la sphère du porte-avions la
contamination dé de l'équipage du
charles de gaulle qui a qui a défrayé la
chronique dans nos rangs et qui continue
de la défrayer certains disent que
l'institution n'a qu'à communiquer des
informations inexactes pouvoir voire
même mensongère écrit lesquelles s'est
encore compliquée on a encore du mal à y
voir on va sans doute pouvoir en
discuter avec les interlocuteurs et les
responsables de la défense
mais certains journalistes disent
effectivement qu'on leur a menti sur sur
les informations liées à cette
contamination
voilà donc et puis le troisième sujet
qui lui a fait déborder le vase c'est
l'histoire des sportifs militaires
français qui aurait été je prends je
prends le conditionnel contaminées en
octobre dernier lors des jeux mondiaux
de
en chine qui a été révélé ces derniers
jours et les attaques journalistes
pensent que les l'institution militaire
n'a pas forcément tout dit ou dit des
choses qui ne correspondent pas à la
réalité des institutions militaires
nient tout content ou qu'ovide positif
pour danser danser dans ce groupe de
journalistes de parent de motifs tiff
militaire juillet arrivée alors vous
parlez également de problèmes
structurels qui n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
un et pas forcément de cette crise
sanitaire qui ont été exacerbées quel
type de problèmes structurels vous êtes
un spécialiste défense et vous dites il
faut pas forcément la primauté de
l'information mais en tout cas les xacti
t l'exactitude de ses informations en
tant que spécialiste il est clair que le
seul la défense est un sujet compliqué
complexe et et qu'on y touche très vite
à des questions sensibles car me parle
de vie et de mort on y parle de secret
défense
on y parle de souveraineté
d'indépendance française est donc scellé
journaliste et spécialiste des questions
de défense sont habitués à travailler
avec des informations fiables recoupé
des chiffres précis pour justement se
forger une crédibilité auprès de leurs
interlocuteurs
et quand on a en ce moment des dés son
cloche divergents des gens qui donnent
des chiffres approximatifs voire même
pas de chiffres tout cela crée quelque
chose de malsain
par ailleurs et ça c'est une dérive
institutionnelle pas forcément lié au
ministère de la défense
mais on voit des communicants qui
communiquent en fonction de dax
stratégiques qui sont internes qui sont
se poser selon des objectifs qui sont
interne à l'institution et le
journaliste n'est plus que finalement
quelqu'un qui vient occasionnellement
s'insérer dans cette dans cette
stratégie alors que en normalement le
communicant il a évidemment pour parler
aux journalistes et pour écouter ces
questions et non pas et non pas pour les
prendre si uniquement l intéresse sa
stratégie voyez alors ça c'est quelque
chose de fond et puis vous avez un
troisième sujet c'est un sujet politique
car il ya des journalistes qui se
plaignent des pressions exercées par au
niveau politique de la communication
institutionnelle est bon ça c'est une
c'est également une dérive qui est
relativement
répandue aujourd'hui c'est depuis ces
quelques de quelques années quelques
lequel cette impression précisément des
coups de fil des coups de fil pour des
articles qui entre guillemets aurait
déplu ou des coups de fil pour dire
qu'il faut pas forcément travailler sur
ce type de sujet plutôt deux autres
voilà des choses comme ça des choses un
peu étonnante mais encore une fois
qu'ils sont là pour le coup plutôt au
niveau politique et pas mais pas au
niveau des communicants politiques de la
majorité actuelle ou de tout pouvoir
politique c'est à dire là on désigne
davantage la cible la cible cabinet
défense est évidemment oui alors c'est
accepter un problème qui est qui est
particulier à la défense où vous pensez
ou est ce que c'est un problème un peu
récurrent non je pense pas que ce soit
un problème particulier en défense je
vais vous dire il faut aussi sourire
quand on a des pressions c'est que a
priori le travail est plutôt bon vous
voyez c'est on peut le voir aussi à
faire se peut le voir aussi comme ça
donc c'est plutôt bon ça veut dire que
les articles voilà disent des choses en
est que les articles ne disent pas
seulement la communication
institutionnelle mais moi je constate on
le voit avec la faire démasquer on le
voit aussi avec le fana femmes le fameux
épisode de la rubrique désintox sur
gouvernement.fr que le gouvernement a
tenté de mettre en place et qu'il a été
obligé de retirer sous la pression de la
grande majorité des sociétés de
rédaction des journalistes vous avez
bien sûr celle subie cette affaire on
voit bien que à un moment donné la
meilleure façon de lutter contre l'effet
que nous les flows nouvelle en tout cas
dans notre spécialité c'est d'alimenter
les journalistes en informations en
temps et en heure c'est-à-dire pour
alimenter cette machine médiatique qui
qui fonctionne et autant que faire se
peut d'ailleurs un peu en amont car ça
permet aux journalistes de mettre en
perspective ces informations et de
produire l'information de qualité et
c'est évidemment comme ça qu'on arrivera
à trouver une alternative au fait que
nous et nous pas en désignant tel ou
untel ou en faisant des pressions sur
des journalistes comme comme certains le
trouvent qu on en fait beaucoup beaucoup
en ces dernières semaines
une rencontre le ministère des armées
vous inviter à l'esprit qu'est ce que
vous en attendez précisément c'est la
dernière question vous savez quand il ya
un problème il faut parler en fait on en
face de nous des communicants le propre
du métier de communicant c'est d'établir
des contacts des relations et de pouvoir
prendre son téléphone et de parler et
l'a visiblement il y avait un problème
puisque le comment dirais-je le il y
avait une espèce de la compréhension
entre les communicants et jaune risque
et qui est pour le coup paradoxale pour
ce métier lors donc on va parler on va
on va parler on va essayer de
dépassionner le débat et surtout de 2d
personnaliser les choses parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup d'énervement beaucoup de
l'hystérie aussi peut-être en cette fin
de déconfinement la période est
compliquée pour tout le monde je vous
rappelle que beaucoup de journalistes
travaillent vous le savez bien dans des
conditions de plus en plus difficile
ethnique
voilà donc tout ça va être pris en
compte mis sur la table et je crois que
les militaires sont des gens rationnels
avec lesquels évidemment on peut parler
voilà il faut aussi que les responsables
mais qui ne sont pas décisionnaire les
militaires pas toujours vous avez raison
pas toujours merci beaucoup varié avec
raffray d'avoir répondu à nos questions
sur rt france merci votre invitation
megally en allemagne certains cantons se
font marche arrière en termes de
décontamination au nord-ouest du pays
notamment des mesures de confinement ont
été rétabli hier un foyer de kovy 19
s'est déclaré dans une usine de
transformation de viande
d'autres cantons dans le nord et l'est
envisage également de rétablir des
mesures de précaution voyez l'analyse de
rené sebastian wawer il est médecin
spécialiste en expertise médicale and
unique
il ya beaucoup de réaliser il en
faudrait toujours encore plus on ne
connaît toujours pas le nombre de cas
qui nous sont restés sans pato moore est
un tome est donc on ne prenait pas les
nombres de malades du 2-2 contre le 2e
personnes contactées et donc les huit
équipes d'être d'interpréter les
statistiques concernant le problème que
tout le monde connaît les résultats sont
assez convaincants
maintenant il faut bien voir l'albanie
république fédérale et les décisions
sont prises de façon régionales allant
de soi même un haut niveau dans là
encore à l'intérieur qui vend les
communes par exemple et c'est la fin de
cette édition merci de votre fidélité
sur notre antenne rester avec nous on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes
chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
psychopolitique n'a jamais été obligé de
dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent la haine en soi vient
des lignes ans
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrêmement
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]